get prepped fallout shelter fans the
mobile games major 1.6 update will
arrive sometime this week along with the
pc version the official fallout Twitter
account at Fallout tweeted over the
weekend that it's five days until your
besting the questing with hashtag
fallout shelters biggest update along
with a picture of a fallout shelter
vault door with update 1.6 and PC
visible in the top portion it has since
been updated with four days until you
can exchange blows and combat new foes
in hashtag fallout shelters biggest
update along with the URL for the
fallout shelter website announced at e3
the fallout shelter 1.6 update is
apparently really big really big that's
that's how they described it okay
there's going to be new locations to
explore such as fallout 4s truckstop
franchise Red Rocket new characters the
ability to send your vault dwellers on
quests and an all-new combat system
fallout shelter a free mobile game that
offers microtransactions has been
downloaded 50 million times to date and
allows players to assume the role of
overseer of their very own vault in the
Fallout universe Bethesda is yet to
share more specifics on the update but
we've released this close we expect to
hear more very soon so while we wait
anxiously for Bethesda to push the red
button are you still playing fallout
shelter what's the worst thing you've
done is overseer let us know in the
comments and for everything retro
radioactive and really big keep your
sights on gamespot